avec nous sur ce plateau eugène berg
ancien diplomate français et spécialiste
de la russie bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation alors on le
voit la russie visait visiblement au
coeur de toutes les attentions il y a
l'annoncé par mike pompe et on vient
d'en parler à l'instant de ce projet de
financement concernant des projets
énergétiques dans des pays d'europe
centrale et de l'est pour renforcer donc
leur indépendance énergétique face à la
russie puis il ya évidemment les propos
d' emmanuel macron le chef de l'état
français qui estiment que la russie va
continuer à essayer de déstabiliser les
démocraties occidentales comment est ce
que vous avez accueilli ses propos bon
merci encore c'est l'invitation
on est là devant un sujet extrêmement
vaste complexe et évolutif alors pour
être clair je pas vu dans le détail ce
qu'ont dit les uns les autres mais j'ai
lu attentivement le discours du
président macro à l'école de guerre et
je pense qu'il a repris ça on pour faire
clair et résumé il ya trois aspects
trois aspects dans le discours deux
présidents et des américains bon pour
revenir au plus simple et américains les
américains veulent vendre leur gaz parce
qu'ils ont du gaz de schiste
keller de plus en plus coûteux je vous
écoute
quel de plus en plus coûteux et donc ils
ont ils veulent trouver des débouchés
l'organe je le dis tout de suite et j'en
sais un petit peu il est plus cher que
le gaz de gazprom gazprom vent 37 % du
gaz européen et ils veulent un peu
casser ce monopole et vendent leurs donc
je suppose qu'ils veulent financer des
installations de regazéification parce
que ils vont envoyer leur gaz par
méthaniers et ensuite voilà donc et déjà
les pôles les polonais veulent plus
acheter de gaz russe donc voilà avec un
milliard entre nous on va pas très loin
un seul méthanier tels que total a
financé avec gazprom pour le
projet yamal vous 380 millions d'euros
donc avec un milliard c'est assez
symbolique les projets gaziers
énergétique se comptent plus tôt en
dizaines de milliards donc voilà ma
première réaction c'est de bonne guerre
du côté américain c'est pour l'instant
symbolique mais ça montre bon ils ont
édicté des sanctions côte nord stream 2
voilà la position américaine
alors en ce qui concerne la france et le
présent la con c'est vrai qu'il a mis un
peu l'accent sur les cyberattaques
mais je crois que ça c'est ce qui a été
relevé
c'est un poids parmi d'autres dans son
discours est depuis son action depuis
brégançon c'est clair il veut renouer un
dialogue stratégique avec la russie
ils veulent intégrer non pas dans une
architecture mais un dialogue
justement pour si l'europe son autonomie
sur le plan de la défense défense est là
aussi très large s'est pas uniquement la
défense physique c'est les
infrastructures c'est les espaces
communs la haute mer les câbles sous
marins
donc voilà c'est vraiment très
intéressant la défense s'est tous
azimuts tout espace c'est simultanée et
ceux de oui pardon les manier macro qui
déplore aussi un affaiblissement de
l'occident est ce que c'est votre
sentiment le monde est de moins en moins
occidentale
ah bah oui ça c'est incontestable je
veux dire que
moi qui est en train d'écrire une
magnifique histoire de la guerre froide
que 45 4 ans je le vois quoi le monde a
été bouleversée par l'apparition de la
chine de l'adq est capable envoyer des
satellites sur la lune alors que
l'europe ne le fait pas et bientôt
peut-être du brésil l'autre chose mais
c'est surtout le fait que l'europe ne
dépense pas pour la défense elle dépense
1,7 prendre les chiffres alors qu'il ya
30 ans dépensé 3 4% du pipe
donc on a réduit les dépenses de défense
et on y va
chacun pour soi on dépend aussi beaucoup
de l'armement américain faut le dire et
nous amis allemands vont vont remplacer
des avions et il hésite entre les avions
f 18 américain eurofighter et on les en
ont là on les attend un peu au tournant
ou alors vous êtes européen mais comme
ils ont peur des menaces américaines
commercial ils vont certainement coupé
la poire en deux et excusez moi
l'expression donc dans cette défense
il ya de la stratégie il y à du commerce
il ya de la vente et tout est mélangé ce
que veut faire mâcon s'est donné à
l'europe une plus grande consistance
pour que l'europe et son industrie de
défense
quelle est sa stratégie il a parlé de
dissuasion avec des intérêts vitaux
peut-être que vous posez une question là
dessus
donc il faut que l'europe avance si elle
veut exister sur la scène internationale
à côté les états unis de la chine de la
russie demain de l'inde peut être même
de l'indonésie on parle pas du
proche-orient de du brésil
il faut que l'europe ne soit pas une
seule puissance civile et donc quelle
qu'elle défende ses intérêts à l
évidemment pour l'instant dans le cadre
atlantique
mais il faut qu'elles renforcent ce
noyau ce pilier et d'ailleurs c'est une
vieille histoire
on en parle depuis 40 ans mais on
n'avance pas et la france ce serait à la
manoeuvre ont peut-être revenir aussi
sur la longue absence des français à
cette conférence sur la sécurité de
munich
pas de français depuis 2009 c'est la
première apparition des manuels macron
comment est-ce que vous
c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est vous avez
tout à fait raison de dire c'est alors
munich je connais son single je les
connais ici que l'on était en poste à
paris c'est un brillant diplomate qui
était président la conférence
collections furent alors ce qui est
intéressant c'est que ça peut t'aider
perçue par nous comme une enceinte
atlantique euro-atlantique wac dans
laquelle on n'était pas très à l'aise
qui n'est pas ce qui est pas vrai parce
que le grand discours de vladimir
poutine de février 2007 il a été
prononcé à munich et toute notre
attention
j'irai pas tension mais nos divergences
stratégiques entre russie occident
russie etats-unis ça va pas de la crim
et ça ne date pas de 14 sa date de cette
lorsque poutine est il
il a critiqué le loup solitaire
souvenons nous c'est un peu l'histoire
ancienne la france s'était opposée à
l'international en irak
c'est elle qui a déstabilisé donc tout
laisser les états unis qui sont sortis
de la bm antimissile oui il faut avoir
cette vision stratégique et maintenant
on paye l'addition de toutes ses erreurs
ses incompréhensions
merci beaucoup d'être venu nous livrer
votre analyse aux jeunes beurs je
rappelle que vous êtes ancien diplomate
français spécialiste de la ces merci